should you upgrade from the iPhone 14
pro to the 15 Pro or Pro Max well today
I will tell you everything that has
changed both the good and the bad and
what is disappointing and I think you're
gonna be quite surprised with my
conclusion with this iPhone launch Apple
really focused on the design the new
materials the chip and the cameras
starting with the titanium build this is
the first time the apple is switching
away from the stainless steel that we've
really really liked but was quite heavy
to Titanium which has the highest
strength to weight ratio it is a new
brushed look instead of the shiny
stainless steel and I think it looks
fantastic they also thin down the bezels
and that allowed them to make the actual
size of the phone smaller so it's going
to fit more comfortably in your and and
along with that it has a new contoured
Edge which makes it more comfortable as
well so you have the flat sides for a
really good grip but you also get added
comfort and with this titanium design it
is the lightest Pro iPhone ever even
going back to the iPhone 11 Pro so that
is great now unfortunately the color
options are a bit boring and very
similar instead of the Deep Purple and
space black along with the silver and
the gold that I personally love we have
a black titanium natural titanium blue
titanium and white titanium now a few of
them have the same color on the sides
and just the backs are different but you
guys let me know about the color options
are you happy with what they're giving
us now Apple said that it takes 14 hours
to complete the process to make these
titanium frame and they have a new solid
state diffusion to connect the titanium
to the aluminum to help with heat and
we'll see if that helps with the dimming
that we get and overheating on the 14
Pros now it's also more repairable but
because of the new design and that's
definitely a great thing now the next
reason to upgrade is the new action
button gone is that physical silent
switch that we all loved and by default
you can still go ahead and switch it and
put into silent mode by holding it down
but you can customize it so you can
switch to audio recording if you need
that or my favorite is to launch the
camera really quickly that's going to be
super useful you can also do a bunch of
other actions and they're not limiting
it you can actually use shortcuts to
make your own uh action button shortcut
so this is going to be a really nice
feature now I don't think that anybody's
really going to want to upgrade just for
that action button but nobody's gonna
complain and if you're upgrading for
another reason it's going to be a good
bonus now if you're going to be buying
any of the new iPhone 15 models you're
definitely going to have to get a
reliable case like one of the new iPhone
15 impact or bounce cases from our
sponsor case defy a company that makes
the most protect Active cases out there
with their best-selling impact case
providing drop protection up to four
times military standard while looking
super stylish and slim due to their
twisto ecoshock inner lining now usually
protected cases are really big and heavy
but case defies bounce case offers both
style and protection with six times
military drop protection which means it
withstood 156 consecutive drops at four
feet from all edges faces and corners
and making it even better the bounce
case is now 16 Slimmer this year
compared to the previous version now you
may not know but sustainability is one
of case defy's top priorities so all of
their cases are made with 65 recycled
and plant-based materials featuring Max
safe and being available in ton of
customizable prints so check out one of
case defy's new iPhone 15 cases by going
to caseify.com
maxtechyt and save 15 off your order
today and now let's cover the brand new
a17 Pro chip the first a series chip
with that Pro branding to see is it
really Pro and a big upgrade now we've
been excited for the ship for a very
long time because this marks Apple
moving to three nanometers the first
time in any device and we were expecting
big gains in both CPU graphics and
battery life performance but this was
not what we expected now I want to
mention that I'm going to be doing a ton
of real world tests for performance
screen dimming and heating and battery
life so make sure you guys hit that
subscribe button the a17 pro has two
performance cores and four efficiency
cores just like the a16 bionic it has 19
billion transistors compared to 16
billion so nice boost but interestingly
Apple said that it is only 10 faster
than previously and previous ship
upgrades had a much bigger difference in
performance Apple really focused on the
efficiency course saying that they have
three times better the performance per
watt compared to the competition but the
a16 also had that at that time as far as
Graphics we now have a six core GPU
compared to a 5 Core and apple saying it
is 20
faster where once again that's not that
big of a boost we've had 40 increases in
the past and a lot of that speed is also
because we have an extra core included
so this was worse than we expected now
the cool thing is we finally have
Hardware Ray tracing which gives it four
times the performance compared to
software and that's going to make you be
able to play better quality games like
they showed off stuff that wasn't
possible before with better graphics and
hopefully less power usage which we will
test now what Apple really focused on is
the new neural engine and even for
gaming they have a new metal effects
upscaling that uses less power and
that's going to increase the graphics
quality without needing a ton of
graphics performance and as far as the
neural engine it's self it is two times
faster than the one in the a16 with the
iPhone 14 pro with 35 trillion
operations per second and dedicated
engines and this is what apple is using
to enable some of the new cool features
and to increase the performance now
Apple did not mention the ram but from
leaks we're hoping that it's going to
get eight gigs of RAM compared to six
which is going to increase how many
things can stay open in the background
without having to automatically shut off
and with this new chip we now have USB 3
speeds with that controller for the new
USB type-c port now we were expecting
Thunderbolt but that did not happen we
actually have 10 gigabit per second
instead of 40. so it is 20 times faster
than the iPhone 14 pro if you use the
connector to transfer but if you don't
that will not matter for you it looks
like next year is when we could get
Thunderbolt with the ultra and with that
the new included cable that you can buy
for 19 bucks bucks it has 60 watt
charging support not that the iPhone can
accept that but only USB 2 speed so if
you want to take advantage of faster
transfers you will need to buy your own
cable so overall I would say that the
new a17 Pro should not be named Pro this
is one of the worst upgrades we've
gotten as far as specs that they are
giving us but you let me know what you
think and now let's get into the cameras
where things get a little weird now the
main camera sensor they showed off and
said was better than the iPhone 15s well
it is the same exact sensor that is on
the iPhone 14 pro and pro Max we have 48
megapixels everything is basically the
same but what they are doing in software
is interesting we have smart hdr5 for
better HDR and finally what I've asked
for is to be able to take 48 megapixel
images and actually save them as 48
megapixel so it looks like by default
you will actually be able to have 24
megapixel files instead of 12 with the
14 pro you can also change that to 48
without needing to shoot Pro Rod that
takes up a crazy amount of space so this
is really really nice but that is
something that you could do with the
software upgrade on the iPhone 14 pro
and pro Max but I highly doubt they will
do that they're going to keep it locked
down being much more limited than the
new iPhone 15 Pros now Apple made a big
deal about having all sorts of different
cameras packed into it but a lot of that
is just using more crop with the iPhone
14 Pros they gave you a 2X crop mode
which I really really liked I love that
focal length but now you can tap the 1X
again to get 1.2 and then 1.5 and that
gives you like a 28 and a 35 mil
equivalent jumping up to about 50 for
the 2x mode so all of this is possible
on the iPhone 14 pro now if you're
looking at the iPhone 5 teen Pro the
telephoto camera is identical not only
with the iPhone 14 pro but also with the
13 Pro so it's going to be the third
year that they're going to use the same
camera just with some updated software
and the same thing goes for the ultra
wide it is the same exact Ultra wide
lens so if we look at the iPhone 15 Pro
the actual cameras and the hardware it
is identical to the 14 pro and that is a
bit of a disappointment now if you're
looking at the max size phones well with
that we have a brand new 5x telephoto
camera replacing the 3x that we've had
for a long time this has a very
interesting design where instead of
having the sensor sideways they're using
multiple mirrors and that allows it to
get more light compared to Samsung and
Google and other Android phones and that
is a good thing now it's still 12
megapixel but the actual sensor is 25
larger so we should have better low
light performance as well well so that
is going to be a nice Improvement the
only downside is if you're going to take
portrait photos that 120 millimeter they
showed off well that Zooms in like crazy
so even though that's great for Zoom
shots well for portraits it's going to
be too zoomed in for a lot of cases so
that is a little bit of a letdown
because we did not get that variable
three to five or six x Zoom that might
come out next year and same thing with
the 16 Pro the smaller size that's also
going to get the updated telephoto
camera so that is one reason to wait and
unfortunately we also don't have 8K
video recording which they could have
done but they chose not to now they did
give us a couple updates you can shoot
cinematic mode with 4K 60 so that is
great A lot more software features but
nothing extremely groundbreaking I think
the coolest update which once again a
software is being able to take a photo
and add portrait mode later or switch
where that portrait mode is out actually
focusing on that's all software based
but it's going to be very handy for me
now we have a few other changes that are
not going to matter for most people but
they could be very cool if you're going
to be buying a Vision Pro you're going
to be able to record sideways like they
showed off with the iPhone and it's
going to use dual lenses to get the
depth in that 3D kind of look for vision
video so that's going to be required if
you're going to be buying one of those
and along with that you're going to be
able to record to external devices or
external storage so if you're shooting
prores which takes up a ton of space
that is going to be nice and being able
to just disconnect that plug it into
your computer and edit right away with
that we're gonna have log recording so
if you don't like the super HDR look you
can have all that control for yourself
so if you're a professional these and
you're going to record video These are
some really big changes that's going to
make it really nice to upgrade now as
far as prices this is where everybody
expected a jump of 1 to 200 dollars and
the cool thing is the iPhone 15 Pro the
smaller size is still at 9.99 and it
still comes with the same 128 gigabytes
of storage now the 15 Pro Max now it
actually costs a hundred dollars more
but it starts off at 256 gigabytes of
storage which means it's actually the
same exact price as what I got with my
256 gig model so technically it didn't
get more expensive they're just forcing
you to get that upgrade so to answer the
original main question should you
upgrade I have to be honest this is the
first year when we were sitting there
talking about what's happening what we
got what we didn't get and being
disappointed and for the first time in a
while Angelica our main editor is not
upgrading to the 15 Pro and I'm having
second thoughts upgrading my wife's 14
pro Max to the new one because compared
to previous generations I would say this
is the smallest overall jump with the
least new features and updates a lot of
things just stay the same they just
talked over the same selling points we
have the satellite with the new roadside
assistance but I think that should be
coming to the 14 pro as well of course
we have the new titanium which is nice
change it's very lightweight we have USB
type c but none of that is something
that you have to have a huge reason to
upgrade and some people might not want
USBC if they have a lot of accessories
even though Apple launched a new cable
for that so I would say if you were
previously on the fence I would probably
wait for the 16 pro and pro Max or Ultra
now if you know something came out that
you absolutely would love to have you
can upgrade but just know this is one of
the smallest upgrades that we have had
in years of course we're going to do a
lot more testing and test out things
that Apple didn't talk about I'll be
making a whole new video on that and
testing them out in their real world so
if you want to see that go and click
that Circle above check out one of those
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]